je propose maintenant de regarder
ensemble un reportage qui est le
résultat d'une enquête une enquête sur
l' influence des jeux vidéo sur les
enfants influencent ou effets bénéfiques
effets négatifs
regardez cette enquête de michele pirro
abracadabra le sujet va venir vous allez
voir la mâchoire et crispé le regard
fixe les gestes saccadés
les symptômes sont clairs le diagnostic
sans appel
ces enfants sont atteints d'un mal très
contemporain la passion des jeux vidéo
deux cent quarante mille consoles
vendues l'année dernière en france après
les états unis l'angleterre et
l'allemagne
nous sommes donc atteinte nous aussi par
cette épidémie un mal qui répand la
terreur parmi certains éducateurs et
parents
il aime bien quoi
on m'opère reste indifférent mais ma
mère à l'import à l'heure ce qui se fait
beaucoup de bruit ce qui est bien c'est
la difficulté plus c'est difficile mieux
mieux que c'est marrant c'est qu'on ne
connaît pas c'est
toute façon c'est moderne ou s'amuser 2
et 1
bon jeu
quand ça bouge plus j'ai de l'affection
un moment commence un peu ça commence un
peu à être énervant sinon c'est bien
d
qu'est-ce qui dansent et je peux à ce
point solliciter leur intérêt et leur
attention
une enquête de la sofres réalisée auprès
de 250 enfants de 7 à 14 ans nous
apprend que la majorité d'entre eux est
m ainsi profiter dans un autre univers
surmonter les difficultés et surtout
réalisé des performances toujours
supérieure avec jeux vidéo ils sont ils
participent et il participe avec passion
et il ya une espèce de compétition avec
soi-même ils veulent se vaincre même ils
veulent gagner ils veulent réussir et à
partir du moment où un enfant veut
réussi évidemment il ya un dynamisme
absolument extraordinaires qui se fixent
liste en lui et je trouve que c'est
excellent
qui plus est un jeu dans ces jeux mais
le fait que ça se joue avec un écran
très près du village
alors là effectivement au bout d'une
heure de jeu les enfants peuvent avoir
dans le souffrir des yeux sinon c ces
jeux sont très intéressants les très
amusant pour les enfants
nous autres adultes on n'est pas habitué
à ce type de jeu alors on les regarde
une certaine façon mais pour l'enfant
c'est quelque chose de naturel de normal
ça fait partie du monde qui l'entourent
c'est pour ça qu'il faut que le
comprennent et qu'ils le connaissent et
je crois qu'il l'adapt bien dans sa vie
il ne lui accorde pas trop d'importance
pour lui c'est la même chose que de
jouer aux cow-boys dehors il apporte un
temps il est je crois que l'enfant une
attitude beaucoup plus raisonnable que
l'adulte face aujourd'hui au jeu vidéo
alors si certains adultes s'inquiète
autant de ce phénomène
ne serait ce pas en réalité de peur
d'être surpassé par leurs propres
enfants